all day we've been asking you for your
questions about this book and the Royal
Rift that it has exposed and we've
assembled a panel to answer as many of
them as we can here with me either
former Fleet Street editor Eve Pollard
Royal commentator afia Hagen and joining
us from Gloucester the public relations
agent and crisis consultant Mark
Borkowski very good evening to you all
as I say we've had loads and loads of
questions as you would imagine from the
public and let's start with the broad
one so to frame the discussion we're
going to have this comes from Bert who
asks quite simply and I think it's the
question millions of people's minds is
why has Harry decided to make all this
public Affair what do you think what is
Harry's motivation
I think Prince Harry wants to tell his
side of the story I think he feels for
so long he hasn't been able to do that
and that certain members of the press
perhaps have had their opportunity to
tell their side of his story and this is
his opportunity to have his say to
control the narrative and to tell his
side of the story I simply think that's
what he wants to do and that's what he
is doing and at this point I don't think
he's really that bothered about the
consequences no he doesn't seem I mean
even I mean it seems worse at all as
well I mean even if you do tell your
side of the story sometimes you're aware
of the sensibilities of the people
you're talking about particularly if
they're close family well you would
think so I possibly think he's doing
this to make 20 million dollars and I
think it's really sad that I understand
that he wants to get his side of the
story over although I don't understand
he hates the invasion of his presidency
and his wife's privacy and I understand
that but it is invading everybody else's
privacy and of course he isn't is
invading himself he's telling us things
about Harry that we didn't necessarily
want to know about we used to love Harry
do you remember the old days he was the
most popular Royal of all and now
we get Netflix very interesting the
documentaries now we've got the book now
there may be more
um we want to see them fulfilling their
lives happily I can't believe this is
the answer there are plenty of people
still do love him of course and even
more might be um be attracted to him
because of the way he's handling all
this which we will discuss during the
course of this panel um Mark Bukowski
what do you think just the big the big
broad question
um why the motivation why is he written
this book
hey he's right it is obviously about
money it's also about power it's about
status
um he and his wife are on a mission for
their Foundation they feel that they can
do some good
um they're appealing
um to the values of a younger generation
who perhaps accept the history of the
royal family through the lens of Netflix
and and the crown rather than the
history book but more importantly I
think what we're seeing here is a
wounded individual I mean this is a man
who hasn't had an easy life
um you know he lost his mother that that
wounded him and he's weaponized that
wound
um in he's in a bubble and he's
surrounded by people telling him what he
needs to do and I'm surrounded by people
who are obviously earning money on the
back of what he's doing as well
um but for me I thought the most
disastrous thing if you're talking about
privacy if you're talking about owning a
story in a narrative why has he put his
family in danger by giving away his
track record in in Afghanistan I mean if
you look at Twitter in Pakistan and
Afghan they're calling him a murderer
and a crusader he's put a he's put a
Target on his back for him and his and
if he's protecting his family and
particularly his wife from Royal Family
he's put them in the greatest danger
because I don't believe that they've got
the same level of security would have
enjoyed whilst he was a member of the
royal family there's an interesting
point that's the Revelation that you can
see at the bottom of your screen that
Harry believes that he killed a 25
Taliban fighters during his tours of
Afghanistan Alfie I just want to put
that other point that Mark Bukowski was
making there that um he's a wounded
individual I mean this is very raw this
book isn't it it is very wrong and I
think actually yes we are seeing a
person who has been affected by the
death of his mother by that trauma by
that Griefer that I think probably for a
long time went unresolved we know though
that he does speak with the therapist
and he has been seen using tapping
methods so perhaps this is clearly his
way of working through that and I think
maybe perhaps what he's doing in the
book is that he wants to be able to to
be open to talk about the mental health
issues that he faced to talk about grief
to talk about trauma maybe to encourage
other people to do so but I do believe
that that is a big feature in his life
yeah I mean you go along with that
either it's kind of international
therapy not between him and his
therapist it's between him and the world
I I think that's true and I think you're
absolutely right he's been very damaged
by losing his mother and seems to be
very damaged by feeling always the
number two son I mean he says that
Prince William was his arch nemesis well
look at the title of the book I mean
spare tells her everything doesn't it
but also I think that on the one hand I
understand you should talk about things
we all know mental health is talking
about things he's put his family in
position where I don't think they'll
return the ball and I don't think they
will talk about things because if they
talk about things we get another six
documentaries we'll get another book and
the thing goes on and on I'd love him to
find a therapist and to find peace
somewhere but I think as as Mark says
he's put an absolute arrow on his back
and also I think that he feels what
happened to his mother is sort of
happening to his wife it's history
repeating itself and that's very bad for
mental health you've touched on the next
question let's bring in some more of our
viewers questions this is from Lydia and
uh Mark you start us with this and it
it's the question we're all asking as
well now and you kind of touched on it
do you think the royal family will
comment on this book and address any of
the allegations when some of those
allegations came out in the Oprah
interview particularly about racism
there was the the famous line wasn't
there that Recollections may vary
it was a brilliant statement I I'm to
answer your question no I don't think
they need to at the moment I think
possibly you could argue they're playing
rope-a-dope
um who knows I mean just just explain
that for those of us for those of a
younger generation rope-a-dope
it was the old Muhammad Ali tactic
who've actually closing on the Rope
taking a battering
um and then fighting back you know just
when you thought you know he'd been over
he'd taken a battery and he'd fight back
it was a classic tactic
um I I think that they're very elegant
and certainly in the Queen's um Reign
they were very elegant in terms and I
remember that statement saying that um
you know uh the Recollections vary but
Harry and Megan and Archie will always
be loved members of all family they're
very graceful in terms of dealing with
it in a way reflecting they haven't yet
answered allegations regarding
um some of the accusations that they
have been briefing against him they've
been silent I think they need to know
they need to get the to the bottom of
this they're going to be able to have a
full picture of this and don't forget
they still have power they're all family
remarkable at reinvention
um and one wonders you know how much
more ammunition that Harry is as and
Megan indeed have got to throw
um and of course we have the coronation
next year so there's there's time
to actually make an elegant uh and a
response uh which I suspect it won't be
immediate and I think they will need to
see how this all starts shaping up
they'll be looking at not just the
traditional media but you know social
media they'll be taking advice but I
don't think they'll move quickly because
these are very very hurtful and damaging
accusations but in in some ways
um not surprising considering the age of
both Harry and Williams two young Modern
Men um growing up
um they're not these aren't as
sensationalists as they as Harry would
think it was I think there's more
damaging thing possibly in the book we
haven't read yet absolutely what Eve
what do you think about a response from
the royal family from Buckingham Palace
from Kensington Palace do you think I
wouldn't return the ball
frankly because you will get more I mean
the terrible thing is these should not
be discussed out loud in public
if there was any to be any discussion
you would want it private but I would
not blame the royal family for not
trusting them I mean if he's repeating
things that Prince Charles said on the
day of his father's funeral on Prince
Philip's funeral he said to the two boys
please don't make the rest of my days a
misery I mean that's a terrible thing to
say that really Rings true though
doesn't it really does drink too and and
and this terrible thing that you know
we've had the queen said he died Prince
Philip said he died they could have been
alive to hear all this and for people of
their generation it's it's it's a
terrible shock the idea that these two
boys who we used to think were together
together in this very very terribly
tragic situation of losing a mother and
and being in the public eye and walking
behind the coffin and the idea that
they're now saying they don't get on
that one of them is the arch nemesis uh
the fact that they had a physical
falling out probably is quite a lot of
people because a lot of families that
does happen from time to life I don't
agree with physics of course at any
stage they're fairly common but it's
it's it's it's it's tragic
um what do you think a a response will
they just continue to to take the blows
the royal family or I mean you know some
of the allegations are very very
damaging to say the least of course they
are I don't think we'll get a response
yet but I think perhaps after the
release date on Tuesday and remember we
do have those two interviews to come on
two different networks one in America
and one here in the UK Another Sunday
yeah he's going to do now as well with
another American exactly so we have
three interviews come thank you I think
perhaps we might get a response after
that like we did after the Oprah
interview I think both Kensington Palace
and Buckingham Palace might feel the
need to say something after that because
the Deluge might be too much but I don't
think we'll get anything yet here's uh
another question I mean they're all
related of course they are but they're
all the questions that people are asking
and thinking uh Nana asked this uh I
mean this is this is quite a charge but
people are wondering are Harry and Megan
after you stay with this for me are
Harry and Megan trying to ruined the
king and the monarchy's image I mean are
they on a demolition derby a wrecking
Mission no I actually just think and
I'll maintain this this is about
themselves this is about them being able
to tell their side of the story and then
being able to control their narrative
and actually if in doing that the royal
family feel that they have been harmed
in some way their reputation has been
harmed in some way I think that Harry
and Megan think well that's up to them
that is par for the chorus and that has
to be the collateral damage of us
telling our own story I think that this
is they are thinking about themselves in
a good way or a bad way this is about
them this is about them being able to
talk about what they went through that's
what this is about and I actually think
yes they think that if the Royal
Family's reputation is damaged well
that's what has to happen but I also
think that especially when it comes to
Prince Harry that part of this is
because there hasn't been a
Reconciliation so they're like okay let
us talk about what happened and
hopefully that might build a bridge do
you think so I mean you know it just
seems to get worse and worse it does
particularly the allegations about arch
nemesis you know exactly it does get
worse worse I mean diversity let's face
it in all families there are two or
three generations everybody's got their
story you know the grandfather who
fought in the War the next Lottery the
Baby Boomers and now you're young a lot
you've all got different stories to tell
you've all got to and I think we spend
our whole life in a loving way tap dance
between them so I know I say things
sometimes and my daughter who may be
well known to you um we'll say mum you
can't say that and I say this is what I
mean when I say that but I don't mean it
in a bad way I mean this is how my
generation may look at it everybody
within their family tries to be kind and
the word that I don't hear about this
book anywhere is kindness
being sympathetic understanding I mean
there was the world when I was editing
the war of the Wales is was fully on as
you and I talked earlier today 30 years
ago we were doing television years ago
there were battles it was the first time
a public divorce had happened in the
Modern Age and it was horrid and they
got diverse divorced and
because calmness time and then sadly
down his death it stopped
and I think they did the very best to
try and bring up these boys in any way
they thought it was a terrible thing for
them here's a great question which
follows on from that from Artemis who
asks this and uh mark this is the the
question that kind of addresses this
issue of public interest is what
interests the public the public in the
public interest he says why is the media
reporting on this it's a family dispute
why why are we reporting on it
well the question is why has the media
always reported you know he touched on
you know the when she was editing the
battle of the Wales is you know I mean
the media feasted on the abdication
um of uh Edwards and the relationship
with Wally Simpson and the media wasn't
totally this this is headlines it's just
generating clickbait this is this is
falling into the age of AD Tech
um this is stuff that's being discussed
or discussed on social media platforms
people find it interesting people look
at these things and they're entertained
this is a public live soap opera with
some of the most famous individuals in
the world and let's not forget now that
Harry and Megan are us-based they're in
California uh the media is there is
feeding on the story Neil times only a
few weeks ago did a a big op-ed about
you know how the royal family should um
uh reform
um it's headlights across the world mere
fact this book leap from some
um some book chain in Spain
um this morning shows that this is a
global interest and if there was no
interest in this story there would be no
headlines
um there would they would they wouldn't
then actually wouldn't get off the
ground we are fascinated by the lives of
celebrity we're fascinated by those in
public and now it's very it's open
season
um it is now the age of social media
where tidbits and and half truths truths
conspiracy theories you know flowers and
um and that's why we're in the age of
where where data rules and of course
people are making a lot of money out of
the interest in all these stories that
are feeding into every news feed that we
get on our device or even those who
still hang on to analog media
um
well precisely that affair should the
media just ignore it I mean it would
never happen but you you know it's a
family dispute they need to sort it out
amongst themselves I mean no no the
media shouldn't ignore it because then
we wouldn't all be here but I mean there
is an interest and some people aren't
interested in it therefore just don't
engage with it move on but there's so
many people that are interested in it
that have been interested in the royal
family that will continue to be and
you're a Charlotte lewian George's time
there is an interest in this story and
like the other guests were saying yes
you know Harry and Megan are no us-based
you know they're in Hollywood and
there's a major interest in that as well
you know whether we like it or not this
is our royal family these are you know
the the sort of American arm of it so we
have that that mix of
um the hollywoodness and and the
britishness and the culture Clash that
comes with that so many people are
interested have been and will continue
to be so the media needs to run it
doesn't go beyond that as well I mean
well this is this is an
Institutional institution I think one of
the great problems possibly uh if you go
back to the very beginning of this
couple who were adore I covered that way
wedding there was adoration there was
love for Megan there was Delight that
she was joining the royal family
um there's a difference between
celebrity and royalty
and that's the difference in if you're a
celebrity you have a wonderful man like
Mark who tells you what to do where to
go how to say it how not to say it when
to vanish when to look wonderful if
you're the royal family you just carry
on trooping the color will come ask it
will come the whole the coronation will
come and probably
it will just carry on until frankly this
story will become like all stories a bit
boring and if they don't relate to one
another there will be no more stories to
write we're already getting stories from
way back in time frankly four years time
we won't be discussing Harry and Megan
we'll discuss what what Drew George is
going out with I mean that's what
happens in the royal family it always
takes over I can remember going to the
Highland Games watching the queen and
Prince Philip come in for light Applause
between mother coming in with Princess
Margaret praise girls Charles and Diana
come in and the place went bananas
because they were new they were fresh
they were young this is life all too
much for you mark hope not
I don't think you can do anything I'm
weeping I'm weeping
that might be happening in some of the
royal palaces at the moment with some of
these Revelations that might so listen
uh no now we've got you there Marco let
me put Ross's question to you um will
this not actually deepen the current
Rift within the family you know if the
intention is we hear from the Harry and
Megan's side is to say well you know we
want a Reconciliation we want to
discussions out in the open the
revelations are driving the other
members of the family further apart
aren't they
but I I think that's um I think you've
touched on it earlier I think that this
is a family issue and I think a lot of
people
um in this country across the world will
will have family disputes some of which
are very painful and some of which last
for many years
um I think the royal family would rather
have
um Harry and Megan in the camp than
outside the camp
um let's not forget this is about making
the royal family relevant as an
institution in 10 or 20 or 30 years time
um to a certain extent it's going
through a transitional period
um the Boomers you know are passing
um and a younger generation who Embrace
many of the ideas that uh Harry and
Megan purport you know on ecology and
and
um and and mental health and whatever it
is important for that generation to get
better and that's why they had such a
are compelling they were called The Fab
Four you know Megan Barry
um Kate and William it was it was a
dream ticket for revolutionizing the
royal family for the future all that has
gone now and this self-determination for
this group of people to create some sort
of foundation
um that has its own power as its own you
know
um
situation in America is what they're
driving for that's why they're not
listening to any cents but the rough
family have got an issue going forward
Maybe not immediately
um but they do have to think about how
they gently modernize because royal
family doesn't do anything in a hurry
they're very considered
um but this is an issue that there are
many parts of the world who will be
looking at Harry and Megan and not
understanding exactly why they can't be
embraced why all this Pomp and
Circumstance and protocol is not
allowing to be young people to live
their life and um you know that that
there will be a lot of attention now on
the generations to follow particularly
the family of Kate and William and more
pressure on them well that's the point
this is a difficult time yeah one of us
more about um Kate and William I mean I
think what do you think the reaction is
the these Revelations that there was a
physical assault an alleged assault by
Prince William on Prince Harry pushed
him over landed in a dog bowl ripped his
necklace and then of course before that
back in what 2005 was their advice to go
to a fancy dress party in a Nazi uniform
and then we also had
um the revelations in the Harry and
Megan documentary about the Sandringham
Summit where William was screaming in
Harry's face look you know there's been
long been rumors about the the tempers
of both King Charles and Prince William
I I think it would be safe to say that
Prince William this evening is probably
pretty Furious probably fuming that this
has come out in this way I don't think
he's very happy at all I don't think
anybody in Kensington Palace or
Buckingham Palace will be happy about
anything that is coming out of this book
so it would be safe to say that Prince
William again probably Furious so Eve
back to the question will this not just
deepen the rift rather than push it
towards a Reconciliation I mean both
sides need to want to get back together
but I don't think both sides do want to
that's the point yeah and I don't think
both sides will get back together and I
absolutely understand what Mark says
that there are young people who believe
in some of the ideas about mental health
and The Fab Four were a very exciting
thing so I'm afraid
um Kate and William will have to become
the Fab too I think that you will see
for example she's doing this brilliant
thing about young children in the early
years which is very very important he
may well take on many of the mental and
he does take on many of the sort of
problems about mental health himself and
he'll have to do it in a big array
remember he is going to be king he is
going to have it all which is one of the
feelings you think Harry most disliked
about the whole situation but he wasn't
going to have it all and I think they
may change the way they do things they
make it other people in the royal family
to help
um but I think that that will that will
happen I think they will have to adapt
they'll be furious tonight they'll be
hurt tonight there'll be tears tonight
that would not surprise me but like many
many families they will say how can we
stop this hurt and by trying to talk to
one another if they feel that any
conversation they have may come out in a
future book why would you risk it but I
mean there's one issue with that isn't
it because he on that you know the
thought occurs if they do and if you
agree with that might be the the
strategy that they carry on they cut
them adrift altogether and let them do
whatever they want to do well then you
know the United States belongs to to
Harry and Megan the most powerful
country in the world the most powerful
cultural influences in the world I mean
could you imagine a William and Kate
Royal tour to the United States I mean
wow you'd keep an eye on those crowds
they'd be split down the middle
well well it's interesting because you
you just get a sense that
um after the uh you know after the the
last sort of outpouring
um and of course uh you know has pointed
out there are there are two big
interviews still to three begin if you
still to come but you just get a feeling
that America is getting a little bit
bored with it and some of the a-listers
that they depend on are slightly
distanced himself that that is the
feedback I'm getting that they that they
they don't like this destructive sort of
regime that they're on there's this
unrelenting battle this this this
weaponizing the womb which I touched on
earlier
um and I think that um there's always
the soft power there is a great power
and let's not forget the Royal the you
know the Royal household do a remarkable
job of events and we have the coronation
to come it'll be interesting to see
whether or not Harry comes whether he
pledges allegiance to his father
um and therefore does that does does he
lose the power because of that he'll
want to be there because he's
conditioned to be part of the firm the
royal family and and I think this has
always been the struggle for him being
he wants to do more but I I don't I
don't write any any obituaries at the
moment for them for the Americans you
you know I do quite a bit of commentary
in America and there seems to be a lot
of sympathy
um to to the royal family through this
time
um so I don't think it's over yet but
again it comes back to a younger
audience
um you know and what do they feel and I
think that's the crucial bit it's not so
much the now
um it's how we affect the future and how
we influence the future and how we how
how how the royal family contains that
makes it relevant but I would not be
surprised
um someday
um if you look at it and it might sound
weird to say this now whether or not
Meghan Markle has Ambitions to be the
first U.S female president if there
isn't one the time in 15 years she could
run for presidency and I can you imagine
that
I mean that sounds straight out of um
you know some extraordinary miniseries
but it's not far from can you imagine if
you if you said that about Donald Trump
uh 20 years before 2016 everyone would
have yep said amen yeah exactly yeah
well there you heard it from Mark
borkowsky first obviously being invaded
as what she's doing now just become a
politician it won't be fun here I've got
a specific question for you Eve because
of course you edited what two national
titles um so you have those lawyers in
and out of your office I suspect almost
on a daily basis uh what can and can't
we say here and this is a a
straightforward question from Darren on
the issue of a response from the royals
we think they won't but uh this is going
even further can the Royals sue for
libel I don't think they would I mean
I've ever wanted to do is to go into
court and have lawyers going all over it
I think not right okay well there you
are Darren I knew we get a straight
answer straight there from somebody who
knows Jordan asked the next question um
and this is we've touched upon this but
let's concentrate in on it Charles and
Camilla and uh afia the question from
Jordan is what does this mean for the
future king and we've already mentioned
that you know that that heartfelt um
response the plea from Charles to both
his sons to not make the final years of
his life a misery I mean he's a father
who's tall absolutely and this is the
first year of his Reign and this is all
happening even before his coronation
before his you know pompan ceremony is
sent to the throne
um I think for Charles and Camilla it
means that they are in for a bumpy ride
um and I think those words that Harry
described in his book don't make my last
year as a misery I find that quite sad
actually to be honest I did I find that
very sad I would like to think that a
Reconciliation can be achieved but there
also should be Lessons Learned From all
sides here and we talked about the
modernization of the royal family when
it comes to Harry and Megan that was a
prime opportunity to have that
modernization to have this young power
couple not to mention a young woman of
color within the royal family that could
have modernized it and and appealed to a
whole swathe of people in the
Commonwealth and in the Realms who look
more like Megan than other people do and
that could have been a way to make the
royal family continue to be relevant and
actually the way that this is played out
will have an effect in the Realms in the
Commonwealth you know I'm from a
commonwealth country that's where my
Heritage is from from Ghana and you know
I have spoken to people on the ground
there and they talk about this and they
think well that you know they're saying
but you know if you can't make a black
woman welcome in the royal family what
are we doing being part of the
Commonwealth what does that mean for us
there's a trickle-down effect here and
you know King Charles is going to have
to address that address the way that
this is all played out into how it
affects the Commonwealth in the Realms
and that may not be felt for many many
years it's not going to be an immediate
thing but it is an issue and it's going
to continue to be an issue and let's
remember that if they had agreed to this
modernization which could have been
um Harry and Megan half in half out
part-time working Royals part-time doing
things that they cared about this
probably wouldn't have happened we
probably wouldn't have been here no
biography no Netflix documentary none of
all this as you said airing my dreams
institution to adapt yeah Keith what do
you think of that I mean well I think
George is going to have to get away from
Ghana because that's that's what the
royal family as Mark says it's gone on
for years they don't see things as
tomorrow next week it's it's it's an
institution it's a generational thing I
think they will have to take on board
what are the things that's sad is I
think Megan could have done a lot with
the Commonwealth you could have done a
lot with the fact that her background
was mixed race it would have been
fantastic but also Megan has a history
has a history of not seeing her own
father I mean her own father did she
think let her down by working with
Germans but that's not a terrible crime
I mean he's had a heart attack what
would she do would she never see him in
your diet and she'll never see him and
this is I mean she has a family that's a
very very mixed up family the only
person she gets on with is her mother
and yet she lived with her father for
six years and he paid for her very
expensive very good education so people
are saying what sort of girl is this
she's letting her husband make the same
mistakes with his father as she did with
hers and why can't they
swallow it down remember they will be
alive long after Charles and Camilla
and they can make things their way
swallow your pride as many people have
had to deal with your parents and love
them because
I'm sure in their hearts they did the
very best for their children and Mark
you uh mentioned of course we've got a
coronation this year
does Harry does Megan do they both have
a huge bargaining chip here because they
seem to be making clear at this point or
in fact not clear whether they'll attend
or not surely they must be there
but of course that that is the uh that's
a Jeopardy isn't it this this the will
they won't they will carry forward the
narrative will generate the sort of
commentary and headlines that we
previously talking about
um the fact by not declaring either way
um gives them a huge amount of
opportunity to posit their story again I
mean I think that um
yes in some ways they do have to be
there but in a sense for Megan Harry is
uh if they continue uh this style of a
tank
um that if they don't go that they can
play the the poor S card once again and
they would generate a huge amount of
sympathy so it's it's a delicate balance
um to to strike and I just want to go
back on one other point that um uh a
fear mate is that when you're talking
about female members of the royal family
what Megan didn't recognize is just how
long it takes the royal family to make
decisions it works at a glacial Pace
because it's an institution but the fact
is they wanted to change there and then
they wanted everything to happen and of
course that gave us an indication he
didn't quite understand the job that she
was taking and let's make no bones about
it it is a job and if you think about
Sophie Wessex and a terrible way that
she was she was treated by the media
where she was she was exposed by the
fake shake and we know where that landed
up with the news of the world you know
she's gradually integrated herself and
has immense self-power within the royal
family and I think it takes a while and
possibly that's why you know Harry has
you know so much
um an ease to a certain extent because
many of the lugs in his life clearly
didn't want the job of being seeing or
didn't want to be his long-term wife
through it because both being English
they could see how difficult this job is
and it is difficult it isn't glamorous
it's not some Disney asks job you are
turning up on a cold Winter's day in
Kettering to open up a you know a health
center
um and you have to take priorities but
they wanted that change immediately then
that isn't going to happen and we see
that around us a lot where people are
demanding change faster many big
institutions not just royal family
cannot change as quickly as people
expect them to do and it's a real
problem because they attract really
negative PR because they can't change at
that speed this question then is from
John who asked why is Harry who claims
to find the Press so abhorrent so
willing to use the press to fight his
own Corner Mark Bakowski I mean he of
course claims that uh the Press were
being used against him but clearly he is
using them certainly through through the
means at his disposal through the
interviews and through this book
well he's playing with the devil that's
for sure I mean he doesn't have any
respect for the media
um I don't think many members of the
royal family
um do to to be frank
um but they have their supporters they
have the people that they trust they can
filter them out through those sort of
people there's always sort of you know
contradictions in terms of what their
output is
um but they just throw it out there I
mean it's like checking a hand grenade
into a room and seeing what happens
um but uh
it doesn't feel tactical it feels it's
feeling desperate and I don't think you
know they're blessed with
um critical voice when every
organization needs someone to sense
check what they want they just want to
get on with it and do it their way and I
think they've had issues
um there's now A very wise Soul stepping
into
um the foundation an old journalist know
who's a very accomplished piano Tim Burt
I think he's going to be giving them
some help he's he's certainly a very
clever individual from a very big you
know from from a good background so but
you've got to listen and um and I think
that um if you are a publisher and
you've spent a lot of money on this book
which they have they want to get as many
sales as possible and to do that you
need to use the media and that's what's
going on here
um I don't think this leak is planned
it's on the publicity stunt this is a
bit of a [ __ ] up
um but it needs a lot of publicity
because also this book hasn't been
released at the normal time you'd
release a book in that key October
period running up to Christmas to
capture those Christmas sales it's away
from that it's got its own room probably
putting some distance away from the
death of the queen admittedly but this
is going to sell to the top of the best
sellers list
um and that again is driven by the power
of PR the power of the noise that's
being created signal listen we're nearly
out of time um Eve just give us the view
from the cold face as a former editor
yourself and you talked about the war of
the Wales is 30 years ago and more I
mean it's it's quite a murky World there
isn't it both sides briefly they breathe
through sources your phone rings and
somebody tells you something that was a
strange and a short interlude but it was
very very difficult and there were PR's
on both sides and of course you know you
get information when you're an editor or
a newspaper person from The Butcher from
the Candlestick maker from everybody
um but it did come to an end because
they did ratify a separation then
divorce and then
life carried on until sadly Princess
Diana died so tragically my feeling is
the Royal Family
cleverer than that now and they're more
aware of the fact that there will be
lots of people who feel very sympathetic
to Harry and Megan there will be many
many many I mean even in America they're
saying the Americans are getting bored
by the wine they say they're living in
this beautiful house
um if you've ever been to where they
live I mean I'd like to live in that
area it's stunning they're surrounded by
as Mark says very very Posh American
successful Americans who are worried
about the Battle they're having all
across you know there's blood across the
newspapers
um
you can't keep on doing that I just want
to hear from afir on that you know
there's that conundrum isn't there
resenting press intrusion but of course
needing it to get your side out
absolutely and so therefore they will
use the sections and the members of the
press that they trust that they like you
know there was a point where um Harry
and Megan decided that they weren't
using the Royal Rosa they publish a list
of trusted journalists that they were
going to go with and that's what they've
decided to do because yes they do need
to get out there aside from the
narrative and they're going to do that
with the members of the press that they
trust and they're going to shun the
others and I mean I would do the same do
you think it's working
do I think it's working that's a big
question they're getting their narrative
out there aren't they they're getting
the publicity and and they're always
going to be prepared for the negative
press because that always comes part and
parcel with them when they talk about it
whether it's working let's see on
Tuesday where the book ends up on the
best seller chart well listen we are out
of time we've covered a lot of ground
there's an awful lot more to discuss
maybe we'll come back when the book is
formally
releasedovsky thank you all very very
much indeed for your input